[Music]
there are a few industries that have
been harder hit by the pandemic
than the cruise industry normally these
ships would be packed with thousands
of passengers and crew members but this
particular ship is almost
empty it's just a skeleton crew
maintaining it it's very very difficult
to go this long with the business and
not have any income
on march 13 2020 the cdc issued a
no-sail order
for ships in american waters essentially
placing
the entire cruise industry on pause
and that pause has been expensive
according to a recent analysis
last year's suspension resulted in an
estimated loss
of over 32 billion dollars in economic
activity and 254
000 jobs but the impact of those numbers
isn't just confined to the cruise lines
and their crews
the cruise industries crisis is also
being felt
in cruise dependent businesses like
ports
port canaveral is located on florida's
atlantic coast
50 miles outside of orlando this
is port canaveral's brand new cruise
terminal
last june after four years of
construction the 155 million dollar
terminal
was finished just in time for summer
sailing season
but to date no passenger has ever set
foot in terminal 3.
in fact it's now been over a year since
any passengers have set
sail on a cruise ship in american waters
leaving many wondering
when will the ships finally be able to
set sail again i'm here at port
canaveral's brand new terminal 3
which in normal times would welcome
thousands of passengers
for carnival cruises new ship but
because it's the pandemic there's
absolutely no one here it's a vacant
parking lot
a huge brand new vacant building like
the rest of the cruise industry in the
united states
port canaveral is awaiting further
instructions from washington
as to how to safely open during the
pandemic but despite
lobbying from all of the cruise lines
and everyone else connected to the
industry like the ports
washington has been slow to issue
guidance as to how to restart cruises
in the united states and hasn't really
given much financial aid to places like
port canaveral
this will deliver urgently needed relief
to our nation's families workers and
businesses
last year when airlines hotels and other
travel related industries received
government assistance
many cruise related businesses were left
out
we've been down basically for a full
year
as of this week and there's no end to
the
downturn at this point captain john
murray is the ceo of port canaveral
which before the pandemic was the second
busiest cruise port
in the world you know i i'd not like to
even refer to it as a bailout it's it's
it's to sustain our business operations
sustain the uh
the uh the uh strategic aspect of the
seaport
many u.s ports are a mix of crews and
cargo
but at port canaveral the cruise side
makes up about 80 percent of its revenue
to make ends meet the port has been
surviving on cash
it had set aside for construction we
went from you know making
reasonable amount of money down to
nothing overnight
to losing money overnight it's been
quite a shock to our system
we'll be fine for the balance of this
year but at some point
the the cash we're burning out will
eventually run up
[Music]
according to murray every year the port
generates 2.6 billion dollars in
economic impact
24 000 jobs 900 million dollars in wages
and 74 million dollars in tax revenue
this has been a a tremendous impact had
a tremendous impact on our community
everyone that supports the cruise
industry a lot of jobs have been uh
sidelined all the longshoremen the folks
that load and discharge ships they're
they're not doing anything right now and
in the prior stimulus packages that have
come out
the airlines have got a vehicle to get
money the
airports rapid transit
railroads everybody's had a vehicle and
seaports never did
so no seaports in the united states have
had any
federal relief up to this point